[Music]
Sciences for products being certified by
informed spore is definitely valuable to
myself as an elite athlete with all the
trick testings we have to go to being at
the level that we're at we simply don't
trust anything without that
certification and we encourage riders
never to take anything without that
certification as an athlete I'm
competing at the highest level so I want
to ensure that I feel comfortable with
having the assess products and knowing
that I can rely and trust them we know
they're being made in controlled
environments and that we're getting a
really good quality product so that's
really reassuring as an athlete for me
even as a coach knowing that my athletes
are taking good products it's the
difference between a program going
forward and a program not any small
slip-up next thing we've got an athlete
he's gone positive it's just one term
sent straight forward if someone goes so
does the program for us being drug
tested as rigorously as we are you
really just can't afford anything in the
fact that science and sport has done the
back checking for us so that we know
that any product of theirs that goes in
our system is not going to be something
we have to worry about it's a huge sigh
of relief I don't have to worry on race
day about anything else other than my
racing and I'm using the best products
on the market